as this heat wave continues it really
poses a threat to anyone outdoors it's
especially dangerous for those
struggling with homelessness mary jane
belliesa joins us live in the newsroom
tonight with more on the help that's
available mary jane well sasha
temperatures are expected to spike to
107 and 110 this week making heat
exhaustion and heat stroke even more of
a risk if you're outside
meredith spriggs is the founder of
keradot's gardens the non-profit helps
homeless veterans find jobs and housing
she says with the extreme heat not only
is shade and protection from the
elements important but so is staying
hydrated
it's not uncommon to find people that
have fallen asleep and because the sun
moves
they get dehydrated and they die in
their sleep so we find bodies which is
unfortunate i always double check and
make sure someone's breathing
you know obviously you want to stay safe
so i would say call 911 if you think
somebody is in
distress
the organization is working to prevent
heat related deaths among the homeless
she says there were significant
dehydration deaths among the homeless
population in 2020 that's due to the
pandemic shutdown and limited access to
water spriggs says there are many
community resources available to protect
the homeless from the heat and that does
include cooling
shelters and due to the warning that's
been extended we have cooling stations
around the valley that's open through
tuesday in the newsroom mary jane
ballieza 8 news now